[Music]
ryan grimm senior congressional
correspondent for the huffington post
presents a history of drug use and
culture in the united states including
opium dens in new york in the 19th
century drug experimentation in the
1960s and the current debates about the
legalization of marijuana he explains
why certain drugs were popular at
certain times in history and gives his
thoughts on the government's war on
drugs
back page's books in waltham
massachusetts hosts this event it lasts
about an hour
i'm constantly asking myself what is the
point of a reading and how do we make
the idea of an author talk or reading
sound less boring and the issue is so
few of us have the time in a day to
piece these things together succinctly
and brilliantly and watching ryan talk
about
something as boring as governmental
policy
but how it really
represented something on a map a shift
of how drugs move around this country
and what that related to in terms of
what we need and what we use
what we desire and how we try to get it
is is a truly brilliant thing it does
change the way you view this country and
the geography of it and how we deal with
people
so this is a real honor tonight it's an
important book it's a necessary book
this is your country on drugs is
something that everybody can read so
there's no reason not to try to read it
um
and without further ado um join me in
welcoming ryan graham
thank you thanks alex that was that was
very kind
and thank thank you to everybody out out
there who came out tonight i really
appreciate it
this book
gets a little complex at times but it
started uh very simply
about
eight years ago i realized that i hadn't
seen lsd
in
probably three years
when i met my mass off a little bit
there
um
i i started looking for it i started
asking friends who were going to say
fish shows or they were going to
burning man or they're going to rainbow
gathering places where you really would
expect to find lsd just as much as you'd
expect to find
a beer walking into a bar and kept
reporting back to me no
i haven't i haven't seen it and and the
years the years went on and it became
something that
i was
entirely unexpected how can this drug
that had been such a prominent part of
our culture be unavailable to 22 year
old hippies all of a sudden
and so uh
that's what ended up launching this book
and
uh it also it also uh
i'll start right here
with the with the uh the disappearance
of lsd
so i went to see a professor in my
department peter reuter one of the most
well-respected drug policy researchers
in the nation
acid is gone i told him
how'd you come to this theory he asked i
can't find it i said
and none of my friends can either
i knew i sounded like a fool but that
was all i had
that's not how we do things in this
field he said
drug availability goes in cycles that's
not really a series of trends that's
just how it is he pointed to a book
behind me here hand me that
he opened the 2002 monitoring the future
report which is produced by the
university of michigan and tracks drug
use among american teens
as you'll see he said running his
fingers across the lsd table
use has been fairly steady over the last
he paused and looked up that's
interesting he said
looking at the data for high school
seniors
lsd uses at a historic low 3.5 percent
he then continued with his lecture
telling me about supply and demand in
peaks and valleys and that he was
certain the numbers for acid would rise
in the 2003 survey
drug cycles are widely presumed to be
the result of a combination of cultural
shifts and the effectiveness of drug
interdiction but they're generally not
well understood supply and demand
however inarguably play a large role
when a drug becomes scarce its price
increases enticing producers and
distributors to invest more heavily in
it which increases supply reuter
explained
i told him i wasn't so sure
there simply was no acid out there and
there hadn't been for several years
i rambled on about the end of the
grateful dead in the collapse of giant
raves he was unmoved
check the 2003 numbers he said they may
be online by now if levels remain the
same then you've got something
the 2003 numbers had just come out i
checked annual lsd use it was at 1.9
percent nearly a 50 percent drop
i checked a few other sources
evidence of acid's decline could be
found practically everywhere
in the following statistics in an
ongoing federal survey of drug use in
the number of emergency room cases
involving the drug in a huge drop of
federal arrests for lsd i took the
numbers back to reuter
this isn't a trend he said this is an
event
like all drugs acid is a bellwether of
american society
its effect on our culture in the 60s and
70s was immeasurable and its
disappearance in the early years of the
21st century was limited to the united
states
cultural commentators who look for
trends in unemployment numbers
presidential approval ratings or car and
housing purchases are missing something
fundamental if they don't also consider
statistics on drug use
little tells us more about the state of
america than what americans are doing to
get high
life in the united states of course is
similar in many ways to life anywhere in
the developed world
but our nation diverges sharply from the
rest of the world in a few crucial ways
americans work hard 135 hours a year
more than the average britain
240 hours more than the typical french
worker and 370 hours that's nine weeks
more than the average german
we also play hard a global survey
released in 2008 found that americans
are more than twice as likely to smoke
pot as europeans
42 percent of americans had puffed at
one point percentages for citizens of
various european nations were all under
20.
we're also four times as likely as
spaniards to have done coke and roughly
10 times more likely than the rest of
europe
quote we're just a different kind of
country said the us drug czar spokesman
tom riley when asked about the survey
quote we have higher drug use rates a
higher crime rate
many things that go with a highly free
and mobile society
different indeed there may be no people
on earth with a more twisted and complex
relationship to drugs
much of our preconceived self-image
turns out to be wrong
libertine continentals have nothing on
us in terms of drug use and american
piety hasn't prevented us from indulging
in fact it has sometimes encouraged it
much of our conventional wisdom about
american drug use that the puritans and
the members and the members of our
founding generation were tea totalers or
mild drinkers that the drug trade is
dominated by huge criminal organizations
such as the mafia and the bloods
that crack use has declined
significantly since the eighties turns
out to be wrong too
if there's one certainty about american
drug use it's this
we're always looking for a better way to
feed our voracious appetite for getting
high
for something cheaper faster less
addictive or more powerful
drug trends feed themselves as word
spreads about the amazing new high
that's safe and non-addictive
then we discover otherwise and go
searching for the next great high
we often circle back to the original
drug forgetting why we quit in the first
place
so so what happened to acid
that was the uh
i i originally wrote about this in 2004
and i had a few theories but the purpose
of the book was to actually go out and
find out what what happened to lsd
i came up with uh four four theories and
one of the points of this book is that
there is there is no one factor that
leads to a drug trend either going up or
going down it's always a coincidence of
a variety of different factors that are
happening uniquely in that time period
so
the first thing uh and the most
important thing in this case
was an arrest uh there was a kansas uh
there was a kansas missile silo that was
acting as
the central uh production facility for
almost all of the lsd all across the
country
that was taken down in november of 2000
and the supply was in the pipeline so
that that explains why by the end of
2000 or so uh you you stopped seeing uh
end of 2001 you stopped seeing it
two
the delivery system was disrupted
in the mid-90s uh grateful dead stopped
touring
in 2000
fish took a break
i found a
department of justice field report that
showed that when the grateful dead would
come through a city
availability of psychedelic drugs
in that area
would increase over the next two to
three months
everybody this can think of it as like a
psychedelic postal service that's
advertising when it's coming to town
which brings us to the third thing
which is the collapse of giant raves uh
people who are over 30 here i see a
couple of you might remember in the 90s
there was this explosion of of
field parties warehouse parties church
parties where you'd have thousands and
thousands of kids
14 some as young as 14 sometimes up into
their 20s who would all meet in these
kind of non-sanctioned parties and acid
and other psychedelic drugs were
everywhere so you'd have
the kids would go to the the parking lot
of the the grateful dead or fish show
if they even if they didn't go to the
show they'd get a couple sheets of acid
take it to the rave
and
acid is not the kind of drug that you
need to buy every weekend or every day
or 40 times a day like most other drugs
so you're not going to go down to the
the street corner and say hey hey buddy
you know you're holding any acid you're
gonna you're gonna go where you know it
is and so people knew where it was
so you had those those three things
now
why didn't somebody step in to the
breach
part of it and this brings us to our
fourth thing part of it is that
the production of lsd is is extremely
difficult
and
it's also not very profitable
if if you're going to be an illegal drug
dealer and you're in it for the money
you're going to do something that has
the least amount of risk and the most
amount of profit
because of the way our laws are
structured lsd will land you in prison
possibly for the rest of your life the
guy that was busted in kansas currently
serving two consecutive life sentences
and he's into karma so
the second i've been corresponding with
him for five years or so the second life
sentence really bothers him it genuinely
does
the first one bothers him a lot too of
course
but uh
so
you had to be in the
in the business
almost as a charitable gesture because
you're not making a lot of money because
it's not a commodity that moves well
it's the it was it's five bucks for a
hit
and it's the kind of thing that after
you do it
you know most people don't want to touch
it again for months on end and maybe for
the rest of their life they might say
that's that's good enough for me i've
been out there i've come back
i don't need to see that anymore
now think think about it compared to say
cocaine or ecstasy drugs that are
either easier to get or with xc easier
to easier to make
you can get 25 bucks for a pill of
ecstasy
and when when the person has finished
that
they're very likely to be like hey you
know what i might have another one of
those they can blow through hundreds of
dollars in a weekend whereas that's
that's certainly not the case with lsd
so there's very little incentive to get
into it
but it also became more difficult for
this strange uh
geopolitical reason to get the precursor
throughout the 90s 80s and 90s according
to uh
psychedelic community people that i
spoke to uh
one of the uh key pipelines for
the uh the precursor for llc or ghatamin
tartrate was coming from the uh the
eastern european uh soviet bloc
and
in in the late 80s
so they shut this down mostly in the 80s
so in the late 80s when the soviet union
collapses
it comes back together and it starts
flooding
it starts flooding out of eastern europe
because it's this completely unregulated
capitalistic society
and you know the governments are not
going in and checking uh you know what
kind of chemicals these factors are
making and certainly they don't care
either you know so they're making some
precursor that the united states doesn't
want you want shipped in that's that
doesn't matter it was only until the un
uh came together with this global treaty
in 99 that they finally started uh
shutting those down and there are some
press reports that people sent me to
that show that the uh that bizarre cult
terrorist group in japan that uh
led off some like uh stink bomb in this
in the subway
uh
also was involved in lsd and it was it
was proven that that uh lsd had had
russian origins
so
that that supply is cut off in the late
90s so you have this this collection of
factors working together
and it almost vanishes
so i wanted to look at well
is that the first time that's happened
in american uh society and also in
american history and and what happens
to um
to the people who used to or still have
who still have an appetite still have a
demand for that drug what do they do
instead
so i i also wanted to uh make this a
little bit of a different drug book most
most drug books start in about 1965
and they run through american history
sort of like it's a vh1 rockumentary you
know like
you know there's the rise in the 60s
everything's great the parties raging in
the 70s
the 80s things get a little out of
control
then they go to aaa
then in the 90s there's like wisdom
maturity recovery and then
um you know the book will have an
interview with jerry garcia or hunter
thompson or something like that and
and and that's the picture that you get
of american drug use i wanted to stretch
it much further back and try to figure
out what what real people were doing um
not that jerry garcia is not a real guy
but you know what people other than him
have been doing so
one of the most surprising things to me
was what i found about the relationship
between the temperance movement in the
19th century
and the rise of uh opium smoking and uh
vladimir and other other forms of opium
throughout the 1830s so we moved to that
right
at the time and we're talking 1830s here
at the time there was little research
done exploring the relationship between
opium use and drinking but there was at
least one noteworthy study an 1872 look
at the opium boom by the massachusetts
state board of health
the reason for the dramatic upswing and
opiate use it concluded wasn't the
chinese or the civil war it was the
temperance movement
this unintended consequence of the call
for sobriety wasn't unique to the united
states the board found quote it is it is
a significant fact that both in england
and in this country the total abstinence
movement was almost immediately followed
by an increased consumption of opium it
noted
the study suggested that easy
accessibility to the drug throughout
through pharmacies was part of the
reason for the increase but that many
other sources existed as well
one official referred to as a state
state assayer reported to the board
opium has been recently made from white
poppies cultivated for the purpose in
vermont new hampshire and connecticut
the annual production being estimated by
hundreds of pounds and this has
generally been absorbed in the
communities where it is made
it has also been brought here from
florida and louisiana while
comparatively large quantities are
regularly sent east from california and
arizona where its cultivation is
becoming an important branch of industry
10 acres of poppies being said to yield
in arizona 1200 pounds of opium
although this description of a thriving
domestic opium crop might might sound
surprising today the board's
characterization of that crops consumers
certainly doesn't quote the opium habit
is especially especially common among
the manufacturing classes it asserts who
are too apt to live regardless of all
hygienic laws
it puts some of the blame for such lower
class use on doctors as we still do
today who are quote in no small measure
responsible for the moral as well as
physical welfare of their patients
unquote and shouldn't be allowed to get
away with the quote injudicious and
often unnecessary prescription of opium
america's better half made up quote so
large a proportion of opium takers the
study suggests because women were quote
doomed often to a life of disappointment
of physical and mental inaction and in
the smaller and more remote towns not
unfrequently to utter seclusion
the quote most important cause of opium
taking however was the simple desire for
stimulation
and urge hitherto satisfied by alcohol
consumption
opium the report noted was both more
available and more socially acceptable
than alcohol the narcotic quote can be
procured and taken without endangering
the reputation for sobriety in one town
mentioned it was thought more gentile
than alcohol
the report went on to say that it was
quote uh between it went on to say it
was between 1840 and 1850 soon after t
totalism had become a fixed fact that
our own importations of opium swelled
citing a rise of 350 percent
in england one doctor noted opium
chewing has become very prevalent
especially since the use of alcoholic
drinks has been to so great and extend
abandoned under the influence of the
fashion introduced by total abstinence
societies
the board also found it quote curious
and interesting that as wine drinking
advanced in turkey opium eating
retreated
as always in america the limits of what
exactly is moral behavior depend on what
the meaning of is is
by following their version of god's code
to the letter t-totaling americans of
the 19th century freely violated its
spirit
and we see this
then
pretty much all all throughout uh
american history
the i think the uh the massachusetts
board of health put it perfectly the the
desire for stimulation that's what was
driving people to use opium one
one drug becomes stigmatized or or less
available but the the desire to get high
or to or to get inebriated on on some
type of something doesn't go away so it
americans go searching for something
else if they can't find either
what's acceptable or what what's
available
if you look at the uh the late 70s
the exact thing happens again with uh
with the decline of marijuana and the
rise of cocaine
we're making no excuses for drugs
hard soft or otherwise pronounced ronald
reagan on june 24th 1982
a veteran of many pitched pissing
contests with the counterculture while
governor of california in the late 60s
he was eager to take it on again when he
became president
drugs are bad and we're going after them
as i've said before we're taking down
the surrender flag and running up the
battle flag were going to win the war on
drugs
reagan redoubled efforts at curbing
imports further militarized drug policy
and brought about mandatory minimum
sentences for minor drug offenses
in 1980 the fbi's uniform crime report
listed fewer than a hundred thousand
arrests for heroin and cocaine which
were tabulated together
by 1989 that figure had jumped to more
than seven hundred thousand
but the first battle reagan would fight
in his war again was his war against
marijuana which required laying siege to
the once ignored base of liberal
resistance northern california
his campaign against marijuana
production camp began in the harvest
season of 1983.
u2 spy planes and military helicopters
flew over the golden state looking for
green crops
by the fall corn wheat soybeans and the
like have turned brown making cannabis
easy to spot from the sky
the d.a reported seizing 64 000 plants
with an estimated value of 130 million
dollars
federal law enforcement figures marched
in the streets chanting war on drugs war
on drugs
the opposition printed bumper stickers
demanding u.s out of humboldt county
the 1984 hall was three times larger
nationally
pot plant seizures rose from about 2.5
million in 1982 to more than 7 million
in 1987
in an amount that rivals the
government's previous estimate of the
entire domestic crop
reagan even began to go after quote
ditchweed a wild variety of hemp that
has no potential to get a user high
the first year that the white house kept
data for ditch wheat eradication it
claimed to have uprooted about 9 million
plants
that number was up to more than 120
million by 1989 and reached i'm serious
about this
half a billion in 2001.
unsurprisingly
such sustained effort drove up the price
of marijuana
the dea closely tracks drug prices and
purity although it doesn't often make
the data available publicly it did so
most recently in 2004 and the numbers
include a startling if misunderstood
observation
quote the marijuana price trends are not
highly correlated with trends in in
prices of other drugs over time the
report reads while the price of powder
heroin and to a lesser extent crack were
falling during the 1980s the average
price of marijuana generally rose
an eighth of an ounce of pot in 1981 and
2002 dollars was going for 25 dollars
it stayed roughly the same in 1982 by 86
it was up to 53 dollars and it hit a
high of 62.91
150 rise over 10 years
coke meanwhile became much more
affordable
it cost it cost nearly 600 a gram in 82.
as reagan directed resources toward the
pot battle coke's price began to tumble
by 89 it was down to 200 a gram cheaper
in real terms than it had been during
the last national coke binge a century
earlier
at the same time average purity levels
nearly doubled
clearly
the price trends are highly correlated
but the correlation is a negative one
in the eighties price increases in
marijuana drove demand toward other
drugs
the war on drugs hard soft or otherwise
helped persuade pot smokers to put down
the bong and pick up the pipe the mirror
or the needle
and like i said at the beginning
any drug trend is the result of a bunch
of different coinciding factors so
reagan's war on marijuana you know can't
be said to uh be the sole cause for the
the rise of cocaine in the 80s and i
actually did a uh radio interview with
ron reagan the other day and he said uh
so i hear
you uh you think my pops uh response for
bringing cocaine into into america in
the 80s
i said no not quite but
certainly he was investing billions of
dollars of resources
going after marijuana
which drove up its price
and that does help to drive people
towards the the drugs that where the
prices are going down
the explicit policy of the dea
is to is to influence the the price of
drugs that's they're not trying to get
rid of drugs but their stated goal is to
increase uh the the price of drugs so
which they say will then uh reduce
demand so by their own theory
the impact of their policy in the late
70s and most especially in the early 80s
going after marijuana
drove people towards cocaine
cocaine though also fit with uh with
with the 80s times and so that's another
uh theme of the book that
you can tell a lot about america by what
people are doing to get high and you you
have these cultural moments and these
culture moods that mesh and a drug comes
in and it's and it's the appropriate one
for the time uh so the 80s were
a good example of that so let me read a
little bit of that
and part of it part of the reason is
i argue in the pages before this is the
collapse of the collapse of the
manufacturing economy so
the the
the collapse of american manufacturing
left more than a psychic need however it
also left a vacuum in the economy which
the non-goods producing service industry
rushed to fill
according to a 1992 new york times story
the quote there were more jobs created
within new york city in the 1980s
overwhelmingly high skilled high-paying
managerial professional and technical
jobs than there are people in buffalo
the state's second largest city
we became a nation of middle managers of
bankers and bureaucrats of adjusters
accounters and wait persons
and drug dealers
from the importer to the distributor to
the guy on the corner
peter reuter the maryland professor who
helped me with my original lsd article
has made a career out of examining the
economics of illegal businesses
one of his most startling observations
is that the koch trade indeed the entire
drug trade is essentially a service
industry because the street price of a
dose of cocaine is many many times
higher than the cost of merely
manufacturing it
as with any retail good some of the
excess covers the seller's profit
some covers what accountants call
transportation in costs but much more
goes toward reducing the risk of product
seizure and employee arrest the
principal perils of providing an illegal
service
those perils became less significant the
more the south the south florida koch
industry became entrenched as cocaine's
price fell throughout the decade it
became available to consumers of more
moderate means it trickled down so to
speak spreading across the country in
both powder and crack form
during its high-priced heyday however
coke was known as a professional's drug
employees of the legal service industry
benefited from this benefited from this
product of the illegal ser of the
illegal service industry as they worked
long hours in their burgeoning sector of
the economy it's its exclusivity evoked
a cloistered world that both the
upwardly mobile and the severely imp
impoverished dreamed of being a part of
unemployment had climbed in the late 70s
as plants shut down and american cities
crumbled
stagflation meant that wages and job
growth were falling while prices were
rising a phenomenon that some economists
had thought impossible
by the close of the decade inflation was
approaching 15 percent and interest
rates had risen above 20 percent
to lasso the beast reagan severely
tightened monetary policy
cutting the money supply and
intentionally driving the the country
into a recession
the reagan recession as it became known
hit hard in the summer of 1981 and
persisted for the next year and a half
the president's approval rating bottomed
out in the mid 30 percentiles and in the
1982 midterm elections democrats picked
up more than two dozen congressional
seats
america was no longer a place where
things were made it was a place where
things were shuffled around
cocaine slotted nicely into the new
economy
the reagan recession had
disproportionately affected urban blacks
and latinos and american cities were
teaming with unemployed men eager to
earn a living
eager to earn a living distributing the
drug cutting it or defending territory
where it was sold
the economy needed the pick-me-up that
selling coke provided
the banking industry had been banged up
by the recession and was glad to have
the influx of capital bought brought by
the cocaine biz
the economist reported that 44 miami
banks were given international charters
in 1982 compared to 10 in 1978.
another 36 foreign banks opened branches
in miami during that period
at least 40 city banks refused to report
cash deposits of more than ten thousand
dollars as required by law throughout
the seventies and into the eighties
and at least four banks authorities
estimated were bought and controlled by
drug dealers
as their trade spread across the country
dealers found still other banks eager to
deal in cocaine cash
much of the money that went to foreign
producers ended up back in the american
economy too laundered through the
panamanian branches of u.s banks
by the late 80s a few banks had become
to come had begun to come under
suspicion as their money laundering
became too blatant
but the penalties were so laughably
small that even when the banks did get
caught they often still benefited from
the transaction
a beverly hills branch of the american
express bank was caught laundering 100
million dollars belonging to juan garcia
abrego operator of a notorious cartel
with close connections to the then
mexican government
in a 1994 congressional hearing chairman
henry gonzalez a texas democrat noted
that the 950 000 fine less than one
percent of the laundered cash meant that
the bank still profited from the
exchange
citibank which since the 1950s had been
the most active u s financial
institution in mexico was in a perfect
position when
cocaine trafficking moved from the
caribbean westward
mexican playboy raul salinas was
discovered to have laundered hundreds of
millions through citibank his brother
president carlos salinas a prominent
ally in the u.s drug war was estimated
to have made off with some 5 billion
himself
in two and a half years of investigation
beginning in 1986 senator john kerry's
committee looking into links between the
cia and the contras also turned up ties
between drug cartels in the banking
industry
one hearing involved the medellin
cartel's top accountant ramon milian
rodriguez who had been busted laundering
billions through the new york-based bank
first boston
a committee member suggested that he
quote must be very clever to have
cleaned up so much to have cleaned up so
much cash
well first boston paid a fine of 25 000
and i'm doing 42 years rodriguez
responded who do you think is clever
so i don't know how our time is but if
anybody has any questions um
i've found it at these readings there
often are a lot of them um
cursor from russia and i didn't quite
understand what you meant by precursor
okay so
uh lsd
uh basically comes from morning glory
seeds
but you uh
the morning glory seeds are are turned
into this precursor that they call e.t
or or gotta mean tartrate
without er gotta mean tartrate it's
effectively impossible to uh
right to make lsd and
i don't know of anybody that can uh you
know on an industrial level that can be
remotely profitable turn the morning
glory seeds you're not doing that in
your trailer or or whatever like missile
silo lab you might be operating out of
so you need this er gotta mean tartrate
which which makes um lsd a vulnerable
drug because if you can find the the er
gotta mean tartrate producers
and shut them down
then
you can do what is very hard to do in in
the drug world which is to
really use an enforcement mechanism to
to reduce supply
because you because it's so hard to make
it in uh
underground it makes it that much more
vulnerable it's it's similar to uh
quaaludes
quaaludes
required a certain precursor that a
bunch of german companies were making
and it took the us something like 10
years to persuade them to shut down and
when they shut down that was it
now quaaludes aren't
apparently that much fun or else you
know somebody would have figured out
how to do it you know it's they must not
be that radically different than you
know some other kind of downers that you
can get
right
right
now
uh i don't want to
spoil the book but
the chinese have uh
gotten
into the psychedelic business in in
recent years
and
not only can you find uh regatta i mean
tar trade or lsd you can find all of all
of these drugs which rose after
um
lsd disappeared that are euphemistically
called research chemicals
now they existed before
um lsd use but the internet and the the
disappearance of acid
uh increased the use of these things
called research chemicals the reason
they're called research chemicals is
that
it's difficult to
outlaw
a chemical substance
so what the what the government has to
do is say this chemical substance
is illegal if it's used
for recreational purposes if it's used
for a good time
so
in other words uh if you're if you're
making a drug that is for a mood
disorder or um
it's it's for the flu or whatever else
you can do research into that but if the
if the purpose is for
a good time then it's illegal
because
lsd you can tweak the molecular
structure of it and make uh make a
psychedelic drug that does something
slightly different it might last a
little longer it might be less or more
powerful it might you know give you a
a different a different kind of trip
now there's a guy out in uh california
who's been doing this for decades is uh
alexander shulgin
and
he
if you look at the schedule one list of
drugs which is the the most illegal
drugs it's like a who's who of drugs
that he's created
so what he does is he he works with
the molecules of some of some
psychedelic and then he figures out a
way to make it slightly different
then he publishes his results online
and then he never never does it again
the the dea then sees that he's
published it and they quickly make that
one illegal
the way that he the way that he gets
away with it is he says
i'm i'm making a chemical substance that
has never existed before in the world i
don't know
that it's going to be psychedelic it
might be it might not be
and so he says look i might be making
antihistamines
he then he then tries it on himself it
turns out it is psychedelic sometimes
it's just total garbage he writes about
it
and that's it they and
he uh he still has not been uh been
busted and he won't be because
it would be a really tough case to make
have you seen any studies comparing the
use of hard drugs today with that of
10 20 30 years ago
yeah the uh so he asked about the uh
drug use today compared to 10 20 30
years ago and there are a couple of
couple of good surveys
there's one that's conducted by the
university of michigan that goes back to
75
that uh that tracks it started out
tracking high schoolers and it's
followed a lot of those high schoolers
and now it now attracts people of all
ages
and then there's the national survey on
drug use and health which is the the
federal survey
problem with that was they changed the
name on it it used to be called
something like the survey on drug abuse
and they they didn't like the name of
that they thought it was persuading
people to give too many negative answers
in a survey that people are already
persuaded to give negative answers
because it's the federal government
coming to your door and asking you
you know if you do illegal drugs
so
so you always have to kind of adjust for
the for the lying factor in in these
surveys but my uh my working uh
theory in the book was that
you do have to um adjust for the lie
factor but and so you can't really take
these surveys as good absolute numbers
but you can take them uh as far as
trends are concerned
unless someone can uh argue and it's
possible to make the argument that that
somebody was lying more people were
lying more in 1978 than they are today
that might be possible
but in general people you know a lot
have probably lied about the same for
the last 30 years or so so
to the the numbers were much higher in
the mid 70s you see you see a decline
uh
starting in around 79 uh drug use comes
down actually through the 80s when we're
waging our you know it's it's one of the
many ironies of american drug history
when we're
most fiercely waging our drug war at the
time that drugs were actually receding
so you see that you see the numbers
coming down throughout the 80s and then
in 91
you see a
what what some people call a relapse
uh back up
until about 2000 and then back down
again but nev never in the mid 90s did
it reach the uh the mid 70s that that
that's still the the peak drug use if
you don't count alcohol alcohol in it
uh yeah given our current economy and
the the ties you said between drug use
and
um the economy and culture what is your
hot pick for
2009-2010 for drugs right
well um
i'm i i'm also my day job is as a
reporter for the huffington post and uh
the story that i was working on uh today
is about the uh the the 2010 initiative
that may or may not happen out in
california to lead to tax regulate
legalize marijuana out there i'm i'm
hearing that that the people behind it
are are going to go forward with it um
there's a lot of debate in the in the
marijuana world if they should do that
or not and there are big organizations
that are funded by big donors saying
2010 isn't the right time uh it might be
a reactionary period if if the economy
still stinks and you know it might be
like
a 94 ish time so you don't want a
liberal proposition up on the ballot
but the people that are pushing it are
saying no
it's different with marijuana this time
around because
if the economy still stinks
and if california is on the verge of
collapse or by then has collapsed
then it's going to be awfully hard for
people that say no
i'd rather not have this two billion
dollars in in tax revenue
over something that is already
effectively legal you can get a
recommendation for uh medical marijuana
in california for
i i heard about this in the book there
was one that said
an ad in like l.a weekly that said
anxiety insomnia
listed three or four other things and
then said etc
so
so 100 bucks and you've got a medical
marijuana card so this would more
tightly regulate it and say you know get
dispensed with this uh
with this with the medical marijuana uh
requirement because um
and
couple the estimate is between 1.2 and 2
billion dollars annually which there's a
commercial running out there now it says
that would be 20 000 teachers in uh
salaries in a year
so it's a persuasive argument you know
whether or not
that whether or not it prevails remains
to be seen but
more broadly on that
what i learned in the history in
throughout by studying the history of
drug use and drug policy in america is
that it will come from the states if if
marijuana does become legalized that's
that's the way it's going to happen it's
not going to come from congress san
francisco was actually the first place
to ever uh prohibit a drug and it was
1878 they passed
an opium den law
where they said you you can't run an
opium den if you're chinese like they
were like very explicit about it
today we were much more sophisticated in
our you know in our in our law making
but back then they just they just wrote
it right in there so other states saw
the uh salt other states and cities saw
that law
they pass it and 50 years later
you've got
you know marijuana becomes illegal but
first it had become illegal in most
states and in uh most most towns and
counties
it'll go the exact same way in reverse i
think just the way that medical
marijuana
started in san francisco in the early
90s with with a
with an initiative there then it went
from there to the state level
and when it went to other states
eventually you'll have members of
congress who represent a majority of
americans where medical marijuana is
legal that's that's very soon if if
illinois and new york
go which could happen very soon
then you will have
majority of congressional
representatives representing medical pot
states and if you look at their voting
medical marijuana comes up every year
your representative is more likely to
vote for medical marijuana if his state
has already approved it rather than his
party identification
so it really does come from from the
bottom up pressure
i'm curious if you see any correlation
between between drug use the type of
drugs that are being used and the point
in time when uh the fcc allowed drug
commercials on television and have you
looked into that at all the whole drug
commercials on television and how we're
being permeated with this whole do this
drug it'll make you feel better you know
well uh
pharmaceutical um drug use did go up uh
you know has has been pharmaceutical
drug abuse has been going up since the
uh early part of the decade um i've i've
read some though pretty convincing um
studies that have
argued that that's not that's not the
reason why it went up and the the rise
in prescription drug abuse
isn't as uh
as large as it's made out to be in the
press but
like like i said throughout the
throughout my book like
all these different drug trends are the
are the effect of a variety of different
factors and i think that's certainly one
and a lot a lot of the time you don't
know until a decade later when you until
you can look back and and see everything
that was going on at the time and
actually have some some decent numbers
to to go by
the most recent numbers that i could get
for this book went back to 2006 for the
one federal study in 2007 for the other
one because
it's
they're they're so slow in analyzing and
bringing the data out you know it you're
they're years behind
and understanding uh what goes on now
the other television ad i also write
about and it's the one that's
uh
parodied on the uh on the cover here
uh i think did also have an impact on
drug use and but but lifting it
this is the
and uh for anybody uh who's uh
under actually
before i put this on the cover i asked a
22 year old co-worker i just showed it
to him and uh asked him you know what is
this
and he said oh it's that that that drug
ad i said how did you know that you know
you were born in like
1987 or something he's like i don't know
it's just it's just part of our culture
i just i know that ad um
it's and so i went back and watched it
while writing this book it's actually it
was only it's only a 10 second ad which
i hadn't which i hadn't remembered shows
the frying pan
shows the frying egg
says this is your brain on drugs
and and then it ends with this uh
contemptuous rhetorical question it says
uh
any questions
and
and uh
they really mean it rhetorically like of
course you don't have questions like we
just explained everything you need to
know this is gonna this is gonna fry
your brain
there and they're there
this is what it does to your family and
right she wrecks the entire time she
goes through the whole kitchen right any
questions yeah she breaks all the plates
and i like the new one where it's like
uh
drugs won't do anything and they go
downstairs to the basement and the
brother is still living in the basement
with his family they've got they've gone
a complete 180 he pointed out that the
that the new ads that they put out say
that this is just a year after they were
saying marijuana would uh make you run
over uh a child on a bicycle if you've
seen that ad right a year later they're
saying it's it's uh
it'll only make you go down on your uh
couch and maybe you'll you'll be a loser
but so the uh but the broader point was
though any questions like yes
actually i do have questions what what
is that uh
what why why does it fry my brain which
drugs fry my brain how does this work
are there are some different than others
and so
uh people went searching for answers
elsewhere and and they were and dr dre
and people like that were happy to happy
to provide answers
uh
two things one uh just when you ask a
question if you can wait for them to get
over to you with the mic that way it
sort of picks things up and also just
sort of jumping off at tom's point about
um last week on on cnn you had mentioned
something about sort of ease of access
being part of a shift in drug use
you know kids and and sort of down the
hall versus out in the field weed versus
uh pharmaceuticals and i don't know if
you can sort of discuss that shift a
little bit as well
it's a it's it's a really obvious point
but one that uh that struck me
throughout american history is that
uh people do the drugs that are most
available to them and easiest easiest to
get
it's that and also the drugs that are
most acceptable and so
the the
if if your policy is intended to you
know reduce the amount of harm that's
associated with drugs
you you want to encourage people to not
have access to the to the really lousy
drugs
and
that have more access to the ones that
are less harmful and the the the point
that alex is talking about uh goes back
to one of the uh one of the sort of
intended or sort of intended
consequences of of nafta and and this is
uh where we get into a notion that i put
forward that there actually is no such
thing the way we implement it there is
no such thing as drug policy because
all of our other policies economic
policy trade policy health care policy
especially foreign policy trumpet
whenever
whenever drug policy is a concern it's
when there's nothing else that we feel
like dealing with
nafta is a perfect example of this
the clinton administration knew
that
opening up the border would be a boon to
the drug cartels one of his uh one of
his drug policy officials later called
it a deal made in narco heaven
and he said uh to his dea into his to
his drug are
until nafta passes i don't want to hear
a peep from you guys
and that that you know may or may not be
a good thing that's just that's just the
fact of of how drug policy is is uh
treated in the united states it was a
very tight vote he couldn't afford to
lose lose a couple folks who were up who
were concerned about uh the the
increased drug traffic that might come
from nafta i found a department of
justice study that found that the
biggest increase in overland
drug trafficking
in the history of the time they've been
mentioning it was the year 1994 and
nafta went into effect you know january
1st 1994
it was a perfect time to be a mexican
drug cartel leader we had just smashed
the the caribbean trade the caribbean to
miami trade route
and that that pushed the the coke trade
over towards mexico
we had also
decapitated a couple of colombian drug
cartels which decreased their power in
relation to the the mexican cartels
and at the same time we'd
gone hard after the
domestic meth industry in the 80s which
is a bunch of bikers making
uh
a form of speed that's left much less
potent than than the one that was later
made by the mexican cartels so we pushed
uh meth down to mexico too
simultaneously
for immigration purposes uh california
starts making its border much more of a
hassle to get over
so
the the drug cartels are kind of just
pushed by economic and other political
forces
eastward
in texas arizona new mexico which sends
them you know directly up into the
midwest
and you know it's not like the uh the
drug cartels were thinking like how can
we crack this missouri market
you know it's like that is what became
uh available to them that's where they
went and then uh meth becomes available
to uh
to people in missouri and you have uh
what's going on now
i i interviewed a bunch of iowa cops uh
about the uh
the laws that the united states passed
against you know uh sudafed and and
other you know ephedrine precursors
and they said they were extremely happy
about it it shut down
most of the like the little tiny labs
that people were making in there in
their in their trailers
the the reason that they liked is it it
stopped uh
this
terrible problem they had of people
blowing up their trailers and blowing
themselves up and making these just
toxic waste sites where toddlers were
were getting were eating like the the
precursors and the meth itself it was
just a disaster and so and i and they
when the federal government finally
passed a strict like uh pseudoephedrine
law
that one cop said it was like a light
switch like
those those labs like almost disappeared
and i said oh so the meth problems going
down he was like oh no no of course not
like our meth has always come from
mexico or at least you know since he'd
been doing it it's always been an
important thing this was just
you know you know a couple of guys
cooking up cooking up some stuff causing
huge problems uh
you know for health problems for
themselves but but not really impacting
the uh the supply of the drugs
we hear often now that
kids take the medicines from their home
and go to parties and use whatever it is
is that true
i think that's totally bogus you're
talking about um what they call farm
parties with a ph
and
it's it's a
it's a great uh it's a great thing to
write about if you're a journalist
the the theory is that
all these kids
raid their parents medicine cabinet they
go to the parties
dump their pills into a big jar and
people
dip their hands in and pop them
i think for a number of reasons that's
crazy one
is that no one in any of the reporting
has actually found an example of that
happening
that you'll get treatment people saying
it's a problem or maybe you'll get
cops saying it's a problem but but no
reporter has ever found an actual case
of it actually happening which ought to
be a prerequisite for reporting it but
is not when it comes to drug reporting
jack shafer at slate.com has done
terrific work
on this particular issue and you can
just actually just google his name and
farm parties and you'll find all the
research that he's done showing that no
one's ever found this but logically too
these parties wouldn't last long for a
couple reasons
one
most kids would bring tic tacs
you know why like you know why bring
your good stuff if you're just going to
dump it into the bowl and then and then
dip dip your hands in there and take
something else or you don't have no idea
what you're going to bring kids would be
dying i mean this is not that's not the
kind of thing that you could uh that you
could conceal from reporters who really
would love to write the story of this of
this actually happening
now i i do i do write about the the rise
of uh teen drug use um
since 2001 in this book and i have kind
of a
a novel theory i can't prove it but i
think it makes sense to me and so and
since this is the closest to today it's
one of the harder trends to to examine
which is you know which is ironic um
but around uh 2000 2001 you start to see
marijuana use decline
but and it's something like 30 percent
since 2018 marijuana use coming down
the same time you have teen prescription
drug abuse
coming up by about 10 percent
so what happened
between
1990 and and and now or 2000 now to
cause that
there are a couple trends working
together
one of them is the over scheduling i
think
starting in the 80s and then really
accelerating through the 90s kids had
much less free time
free time is something that you need
if you're generally if you're going to
be smoking marijuana it's the kind you
know it's the kind of drug where five
kids get together
go out behind a shed they go in an alley
they go in the woods one person has it
they pass it around to each other and
then
if so if that one kid who has it doesn't
have the free time anymore all five of
those kids
that day aren't going to be doing
anything
but but more importantly i think has
been the role of uh of the internet
uh when you have uh
video games social networking twitter
facebook etc etc and kids are coming
home from school and instead of hanging
out with each other
they're hanging out with each other but
online
it's much harder you know you can't pass
a joint through
yet
you know
through a computer i'm sure there's a
facebook app where you know
johnny you know sent you a joint but
that's not gonna show up on the survey
data
um and so kids who are sitting at home
like that
might still
have this appetite for stimulation as
the massachusetts board put it
and they'll use the thing that's most
ready to hand and that that would be you
know the medicine cabinet nearby
it makes sense to me i can't prove that
so that's that's my take on that part
anybody
i was just wondering i uh what is
the whole
uh what is the pr
president in the government and
what is being done to end the war on
drugs
well we we rhetorically ended it uh when
obama took over the uh the drug czar
said that he was no longer gonna use the
phrase war on drugs you know which is
nice but probably little solace to a lot
of the people who are dying or in prison
as a result of it
the
the most immediate direction that the
white house
can go is probably in its uh in its
funding in its funding decisions you you
have it broken down by uh enforcement
uh and uh treatment or uh supply and
demand
bush one uh was very much of a heavy and
so was clinton very heavy into uh
spending money on enforcement
money on the on the supply side that's
completely wasteful like there's there's
a rand corporation study uh from from
that clinton commission that showed that
it was something like 172 times more
wasteful to spend money on the supply
side because it's so hard you know
ripping up uh some coca growers
plant does does nothing for addiction
rates in the united states because
there's so many ways that that can be
adapted you get one addict
to stop being an addict
and you've reduced drug use by
you know not a non-trivial amount
because it's the addicts who who are
doing who are doing so such a percentage
of the drugs
now
the first step for for obama would be to
honestly budget uh
that and you know he ran on transparency
and an honest accounting so that would
that that's hopefully something that he
will do right now he doesn't because um
he just
it's not his you know it's
i'm not going to bang him up for it yet
but he he adopted the the bush
administration policy of not counting
prison costs as part of
enforcement
that which would be like
you know not counting the treatment
center costs
in the treatment center side
so
if his goal is to get to something
balanced like a 50 50 um spending ratio
and he does it honestly then he and
counts prison costs then he'd have to
spend a lot more money on drug courts
on and on on treatment
and other ways to approach demand
so
that's probably the best direction he
can go there there is some some good
news that i reported this the other day
that a bill that just came out of the
house
uh basically eliminates the this this
campaign this
this anti-drug media campaign has been
running
for decades now um
they there have been a bunch of studies
that have shown that it just isn't
effective and there have been some
studies that show that it actually
uh
inclines some kids to
actually try drugs after they after they
see the uh see the ads
and that's what actually the committee
report wrote when they were cutting
they're like why are we spending
millions of dollars in this campaign
that can't prove its effectiveness
i asked the drugs are for comment
and uh their comment was accurate they
said
this is one of the most well-known
uh pro most well-known ad campaigns
brands in the country it's one of the
best-known brands in fact in in the
entire country and i do not argue with
that
but if that's the best that can be said
for it that it's very well known
then uh it then i don't see the point of
it
the the second point the drugstore made
was if game's not over we we have faith
in the senate that they'll that they'll
restore this money so it's all it's you
know it's a push and pull all the way
through
so
the last question i i asked this if
every author comes through everybody
knows i've done this for a couple of
years now but um
favorite book you've read last year it
doesn't matter if it came out in last
year or you just read it
read half of it a quarter of it or
loving it right now
um
i now some people might make fun of me
for this but uh i
i read
uh toward the end of writing this i read
uh the botany of desire
and i know there's some people just hate
that book
but uh the i thought the the um
the the chapter that he wrote on
cannabis this michael pollan book
was
was excellent uh he describes
he he he goes from a journalistic
approach he calls all kinds of
researchers uh neuroscientists etc and
says why do people get high
and he calls philosophers too
and uh he he comes up with uh what i
think is is uh
the best explanation that anybody so far
has come it's it's very uh
straightforward um and you you can see
it uh you know you can see the way that
it unfolds
and so
i i almost wish that i had done that as
part of my book called all the the uh
neurobiologist neuroscientists and and
ask them that
so thank you everybody thank you so much
[Applause]
ryan grimm is the senior congressional
correspondent for the huffington post
his writings have appeared in several
publications including rolling stone and
the washington post for more information
visit huffingtonpost.com
and search ryan grimm